foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
Carter getting competitive for a good
cause one must show up and show out yeah
it was a family affair as blue along
with Mom Beyonce and Dad Jay-Z stepped
out for the Waco theater's wearable art
Gala the fashion theme Harlem Nights
it's just pretty and this is the era I
think I would have done well in this is
Miss Tina's favorite era thanks to the
event's co-founder Blues Grandma Tina
knows Lawson it was a star-studded
affair it makes me emotional if
everybody looks so beautiful all the
performers were so gracious to fly here
from across the world to be here tonight
and we just feel very supportive and I'm
so proud of Miss Tina and Mr Richard and
we all get to dress up and feel pretty
for a good cause tonight but it's no
contest the biggest highlight was Blues
showdown in the live auction
it's so
blue went paddle to paddle with Miel
Organics founder Monique Rodriguez and
her husband Melvin at the center
Lorraine Schwartz diamond earrings
baby when I'm calling you but just not
any earrings these ones belong to Blue
Ivy's mom so the Priceless jury left a
hefty price tag and we should note J and
B were of course supervising their
little ones bids which got pretty
generous
thank you
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
yeah Blue's fully into it even getting
out of her seat as the bidding escalates
but after some heated back and forth
Monique and Melvin went home with the
bling
[Music]
the final bid 105
000 but let's not forget the night's
biggest winners the kids in the Waco
theater's youth mentorship program well
this is doing something special for the
next generation of performers well this
is definitely about the Next Generation
we have to pay close attention to that
now more than ever ever before so
whatever we can do and whatever anyone
else can do for the kids it's important
I don't know if we've ever seen a couple
who not only give the money and their
time but they physically are there
they're affecting change man in a lot of
people's lives
foreign